this is probably gonna be the weirdest
video I've been in I really I love
peanut butter it's probably my favorite
food just like that I like the good
spoonful of peanut butter almond butter
for that matter
they're like creamy well mixed I never
thought I'd be licking it off some pie
right so ever this is I'm really I don't
I don't think I've every in this amount
of peanut butter one have to be ever
just eat the whole thing so a minute
that's that's how bad all right if I can
do it I'm gonna have Marty join no cool
dirty I don't really have a word to
describe what I'm feeling buttons on my
dog's having a good time
[Music]
what Oh
going down cane and I definitely went
deeper than the last time I feel like I
did way better I mean I was just really
going for it I don't know why but I kind
of was like a diagonal wow wow I'm very
impressed with me Macy probably likes
peanut butter more than Whitey's
high-five so can i crowd myself like by
speeds biggest oh my god you weren't
kidding oh my god I'll share with you
okay yeah please I can't I can't have
any for a while this didn't change we
got a long road together
[Music]